[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay foros o visión política más gay
brokeback la anam de communications and
order y keane santurbán alemanes en
grand slam
anda ya sabes perfiles de vincent urban
working in market infraestructura en
payments buenavista de pullman and
innovation tablet en el market
infraestructura en minsk apartment
interior pensando bank
[Aplausos]
con un tipo de cambio inicial de 117 89
dólares estadounidenses el día 1 de
enero del año 1999 ha pasado la historia
como el día en el que nació el euro
y comenzó a operar como una moneda
electrónica utilizada en los mercados
financieros y para los pagos sin
efectivo
aunque no sería hasta tres años más
tarde hasta comienzos del año 2002
cuando las monedas y los billetes de
euros que hoy todos conocemos comenzaron
a circular el 1 de enero de 1999 11
países de la unión europea integraron
sus monedas locales monedas como el
marco el franco la lira o la peseta bajo
el paraguas supervisor del banco central
europeo la era del euro había comenzado
el libro está a la vuelta de la esquina
y para que no sea más fácil lo mejor es
adaptarnos al tiempo tampoco por favor
sentimos andar que no haya lío nadie
creía que españa iba a estar hoy aquí
participando activamente en el acto
fundacional del euro de la moneda única
europea
[Música]
y lo hizo por todo lo alto las
expectativas eran enormes tal vez nadie
manifestó mejor la enorme confianza
depositada en esta nueva moneda que el
entonces comisario europeo para asuntos
monetarios y festivos
[Música]
el euro suprimir a la inestabilidad
monetaria reducirá los costes de las
empresas y garantizará los tipos de
interés bajos y estables hoy nadie
imaginaría eeuu con 50 monedas el dólar
ha hecho fuerte a este país el euro
ahora que la voz de europa soy la más
fuerte en todo el mundo lo que le
permitirá defender mejor sus intereses
que van mucho más allá de los puramente
monetarios
[Música]
y desde entonces han pasado 20 años un
tiempo en el que la nueva divisa europea
ha pasado por buenos y por malos
momentos algo que por cierto en no pocas
ocasiones ha condicionado el debate
público
porque amigos no lo neguemos la
actualidad es irremediablemente
pesimista el catastrofismo y las malas
noticias llaman más la atención que los
acontecimientos positivos
en nuestra percepción la última noticia
vence a la tendencia de esta forma
durante los últimos años hemos escuchado
todo tipo de pronósticos sobre lo que ha
supuesto el euro y el futuro de esta
divisa seguro que en alguna que otra
ocasión habéis escuchado eso de que el
euro está condenado o que su llegada ha
provocado que haya países ganadores y
países perdedores ahora bien cuál es la
realidad qué evaluación podemos hacer de
los 20 años que el euro lleva formando
parte de la vida diaria de la inmensa
mayoría de los europeos a qué retos y
desafíos se enfrenta
[Música]
pues bien para responder a estas y otras
preguntas y celebrar también el 20
aniversario de la divisa europea gracias
al apoyo y a la esponsorización del
banco central europeo nos hemos venido
hasta aquí hasta frankfurt
[Música]
durbin centro para que éste funcione del
pines davie spiderman y investidos por
man with conference un monto mensual de
armani es 'estable' en el tanque su
libro de maní en 6
[Música]
precisamente este edificio es la sede
del poderoso banco central europeo la
segunda institución monetaria más
importante del planeta ahora tú y yo
vamos a adentrarnos en este mundo para
averiguar que ha supuesto el euro ya qué
reto se enfrenta así que vamos allá
y
y la unión hace la fuerza
y creo que la primera pregunta que nos
tenemos que hacer es bastante clara cómo
y por qué surge el euro amigos de visual
polític para responder a esta pregunta
hay que remontarse hasta los años 80 una
década que no estaba siendo
particularmente buena para los europeos
en aquel momento la economía europea no
atravesaba por sus mejores tiempos eran
años de cierto estancamiento y malos
datos por ejemplo el desempleo en los
países de la comunidad europea
prácticamente se había duplicado pasando
del 5,8 por ciento en 1980 a más del 11%
apenas cinco años más tarde el
crecimiento potencial se había reducido
tres puntos los déficits públicos
empezaban a dejarse notar con niveles
por encima del 3% y para colmo eeuu
principal cliente de las exportaciones
europeas estaba incrementando de una
forma muy sustancial las restricciones
comerciales a las importaciones pues
bien es en este contexto como toma
fuerza la idea de construir un verdadero
mercado común que permitiera impulsar el
comercio y por tanto el crecimiento
económico crear un mercado sin barreras
sin aduanas sin aranceles sin
restricciones para todos los bienes para
llevarlo a cabo había que suprimir todas
las trabas administrativas y terminar
con la disparidad de normas y
regulaciones
si un producto se podría vender en un
país de la unión se tenía que poder
vender en cualquier otro pero no sólo
eso un auténtico mercado común tenía que
funcionar también con la misma moneda y
con la misma política monetaria entre
otras cosas esto permitiría que los
países no compitieran entre sí y
devaluando una y otra vez sus
respectivas divisas algo que en aquellos
años era bastante habitual por ejemplo
tan sólo entre 1979 y 1992
italia de evaluó la vida siete veces en
apenas 13 años 7 devaluaciones
[Aplausos]
ya llevo este create el single market
es la más completa del inai states and
hell bells y reporta the world y the
walt disney último dgt
pero en contra de hank aaron si es en
efecto pero del tipo de integration and
intervención en esos instrumentos de
compartir y ver direcciones pues bueno
con cementos vegetales de competición
que están dando
la dirección de cáncer en el trader 3
min
el zinc revolución
tengo incompleta de box pero pinceles de
tres nuevos textos androids la dirección
de otro software and si sting el francés
fijar una moneda común haría que el
mercado entre los países europeos fuera
mucho muchísimo más fácil las empresas
ya no tendrían que estar pendientes de
los tipos de cambio de las decisiones de
política monetaria de los diferentes
gobiernos o de las coberturas por riesgo
de divisa entre otras muchas cosas
[Música]
y sabéis que la creación del mercado
único ha sido un claro ejemplo de éxito
cumplió con su objetivo las
exportaciones intracomunitarias han
pasado de suponer el 13% del pib de la
unión europea en 1992 a más del 20 por
ciento hoy en día y el volumen de
inversiones intracomunitarias también se
ha disparado
[Música]
y amigos no lo dudéis ni un momento en
todo este proceso el euro ha jugado un
papel clave
ahora bien el euro lleva ya con nosotros
20 años qué evaluación podemos hacer ha
sido bueno o malo para la vida de los
europeos pues atentos la moneda que
compartimos 300 millones de europeos
está ya en circulación 12 países han
iniciado la transición para despedir a
sus monedas nacionales y utilizar sólo
el euro
[Música]
el tiempo del euro
amigos de visual polític durante los
últimos 20 años
europa ha cambiado mucho en algunos
casos para bien y otros pues digamos que
para no también pero llegados a este
punto te hago una pregunta y si a ti tú
qué crees ha sido el euro bueno o malo
para europa pues amigos con los datos en
la mano creo que podemos decir que
general su influencia ha sido muy
positiva que es algo de lo que ya os
hemos hablado aquí en este canal en
visual político ahora bien la pregunta
es cuánto de positiva
[Música]
maneras wins bing alain wirtz text to su
expresividad yo jamás te doy una versión
de disney se destruyan de un fusil y
neuro ping an iván como en lenguas se
expresa martes quienes muestran el
exterior y magnífico different languages
el lenguaje de expresión al estilo
americano por ende estudiado en su
beneficio neto y fidel road y vigor en
bangkok en el director driver el dolor
euros restantes tenemos
walters 16 el banco
estambul a nivel de favor en el primer
líder del torneo de la b nacional con
alcance podemos dpz agresión
si eres table racing slow hours
en el balance of o stability en the
great benefits many many people otros
animales afirma el nombre es prince de
tickets no deja ver en explicándonos no
meten en auto huevos
pongamos sobre la mesa algunos datos el
euro soy la moneda de más de 340
millones de personas y ha sustituido a
las monedas nacionales en 19 de los 28
estados que forman la unión europea
[Música]
desde su nacimiento el pib percápita de
la zona euro se ha incrementado un 52%
pasando de unos 21 mil a más de 32 mil
euros y hoy la tasa de participación
laboral es más alta en la zona euro que
en los eeuu a pesar de ello la inflación
se ha situado de media en el 17 por
ciento una tasa inferior a la de los 70
80 y 90 de hecho el nivel de inflación
de la eurozona en estos 20 años ha sido
inferior al de la república federal
alemana en las dos décadas anteriores
[Música]
son condiciones online
en cambio de condiciones en raids cinco
del final de economía
el auto naftero de raiden sensations
functions valen af
tal vez esto sea lo que explique la
enorme popularidad que tiene el euro
fijaos tan sólo el 20 por ciento de los
ciudadanos europeos están en contra
según los últimos estudios tres de cada
cuatro europeos tienen una buena opinión
de la divisa y consideran que ha sido
positiva y la verdad no nos engañemos no
es extraño estoy convencido de que si te
ofrecieran tener tus ahorros en euros o
en pesetas o en alguna otra moneda que
funcione hoy y se parezca a la peseta
estoy convencido de que no tendrías
tampoco la menor duda ahora bien un
momento porque no todo han sido alegrías
durante estos 20 años el euro también se
ha enfrentado a momentos muy pero que
muy difíciles
[Música]
los años tensos
entre los años 2008 y 2012 las cosas se
pusieron muy difíciles la crisis que
estaba causando muchos problemas en la
mayoría de las economías occidentales y
auténticas pesadillas en algunos de los
países pertenecientes a la zona euro
como grecia irlanda italia españa o
portugal es ahí cuando aparece
claramente la idea de las dos europas
por un lado los países del centro y del
norte de europa países en general con
altos índices de productividad
industrias competitivas y estados
relativamente responsables por el otro
países que históricamente habían tratado
de competir de evaluando sus monedas y
que como grandes al euro eso ya no era
posible habían impulsado la demanda
interna con cargo a fuertes
desequilibrios en sus balanzas de pagos
es decir para que nos entendamos
financiaban gran parte de su gasto en
consumo de inversión con dinero
procedente del exterior básicamente de
los países del norte y del centro de
europa financiación que en gran medida
fue a parar como todos sabéis al sector
inmobiliario por tanto hablamos de
países donde en general los gobiernos no
habían hecho las reformas estructurales
que les permitirá ser competitivos y
cuyos bancos estaban cargados de
préstamos ligados a la burbuja
inmobiliaria préstamos que por supuesto
perdieron gran parte de su valor cuando
la burbuja pincho plan
es un plan que contempla una fuerte
inversión pública para mejorar nuestras
calles nuestros pueblos nuestras
ciudades para que seamos más fuertes en
nuestro capital productivo y creemos
empleo
[Música]
grecia portugal españa e irlanda aunque
el caso de irlanda es un poco diferente
necesitaron de una forma u otra
asistencia financiera en ese momento la
desconfianza y los problemas eran de tal
magnitud que se especuló como habréis
escuchado un montón de veces con la
posible ruptura del euro entre otras
cosas porque en muchos estados europeos
tenían que pagar primas de riesgo tan
altas que hacían que su situación fuera
del todo insostenible no podían
financiarse
al final los países miembros de la
eurozona decidieron hacer todo lo
posible para evitar ese escenario fue
ahí cuando el presidente del banco
central europeo mario draghi pronunció
el 26 de julio del año 2012 estas
famosas palabras conforman nuestro
mandato el banco central europeo- está
listo para hacer lo que sea necesario
para preservar el euro y créame será
suficiente
es decir que el banco central europeo-
adoptaría las medidas extraordinarias
que fueran necesarias para estabilizar
el euro de esta forma el bc comenzó a
otorgar préstamos a más largo plazo a
los bancos ya comprar incluso algunos de
los activos que tenían en sus balances
como por ejemplo bonos gubernamentales y
bonos corporativos para que pues para
que las empresas y los ciudadanos
pudieran pedir más préstamos y gastar
menos en re pagar sus deudas la idea es
que esto llevaría a un mayor crecimiento
económico
[Música]
en el país
los
efe
fin
[Música]
es decir que el sistema de autoenfoque
catastrófico les pones consecuentes del
volante
en medios sociales people and stripes
reading 20 de sembrío de media comenzó a
vivir headline news gasten de slim
henson sand pebbles de tres metros de
tipo está el segundo guardia civil y
solar para los informantes del ex post
vivo sin de 10 y fusión de joplin
exhibida en bebedores necessary
uruguay
aceite en understanding the living tanto
el de benítez de del domingo producto
michael programas de ese modo de
complexión banking wanting día de
working on volcó la capital markets
también deberían point en deuda de
elementos económicos en el debate el
tipo político y urgencia we make sure
that the benefits orden francesa the
concert y coleando everyone y mendoza en
cantidad de personas son de clases
medias necesitó el proyecto rosa jazmín
[Música]
sí
pero llegados a este punto la pregunta
que podemos hacernos es estar realmente
preparada la eurozona para hacer frente
a una nueva crisis que puede suceder en
el futuro si uno de los países miembros
del euro tiene problemas amigos durante
los últimos años han aparecido un montón
de mecanismos diferentes que se han
puesto en marcha precisamente para
fortalecer la resistencia del euro ya os
adelanto que los nombres se las traen
[Música]
todos estos nuevos organismos tienen
múltiples funciones y objetivos como por
ejemplo incrementar la estabilidad
financiera y la estabilidad
macroeconómica presta la ayuda
financiera a los países miembros que la
puedan necesitar o mejorar la
supervisión bancaria por cierto lograr
una mayor integración bancaria es otro
de los objetivos clave que ahora mismo
persigue el banco central europeo
computing in las strippers
tengo más de 25 millones no se mencionen
bancos control de feeling de región
resultan muy bien visto en este estado
se comen deposit insurance cáncer
seguridad web hoy por emaná intervenga
youtube safe al regalarles medicación
witbank that s the mexican your love
away with plan que antes
[Música]
y eso no es todo por otra parte se han
reforzado instituciones ya existentes
como el pacto de estabilidad y
crecimiento que exige un límite del 3%
en el déficit público y del 60% en la
deuda pública de los países miembros
y también en virtud del llamado pacto
presupuestario europeo casi todos los
países de la unión europea han incluido
en su legislación nacional la exigencia
de tener presupuestos equilibrados a lo
largo del ciclo
esperemos que respeten su propia
legislación y el propio banco central
europeo también ha visto incrementadas
sus capacidades para hacer frente a
situaciones de emergencia
en fin como veis se han hecho un montón
de cambios que tienen como objetivo
reducir el riesgo de crisis y llegado el
caso limitar su impacto la pregunta es
es suficiente o hay que seguir avanzando
por ejemplo con una cierta unión fiscal
ese es amigos uno de los grandes debates
que existen ahora mismo en europa
pero un momento las crisis no son el
único reto al que se enfrenta el banco
central europeo y el euro la llegada de
las cripto divisas y el block change
también ha hecho que crezca un
interrogante serán capaces las nuevas
tecnologías financieras de cambiar la
forma con la que funciona el dinero
representan una amenaza para las monedas
tradicionales
[Música]
y tecnología
no tiene vida diferentes formas de
expresión y de información pueden dejar
de hacer
bitcoin en zonas sin glorias vencerlos
amenizando el banco brown the world
y esto nos lleva a otra cuestión
importantísima fundamental qué ocurre
con la ciberseguridad especialmente en
un mundo donde todo se registra y
funciona digitalmente
[Música]
weiss
nation state script kiddies 1 donde
ubica muy profesional y no prestan
servicios tv de holger de bandos stand
by desde el martes anterior en santurbán
y lo voy a estabilizar mando witis
rampantes debilite insurance conference
integración
efe de verdad este sentido financial
system integrator es conformar este in
the financial system manejado por su
volcán tensión efecto
wright los fondos están
[Música]
amigos de visual política europa tiene
por delante muchísimos retos sobre
algunos de los cuales ya os hemos
hablado aquí en este canal
y desafíos como el envejecimiento
demográfico la creciente competencia
internacional los desequilibrios en las
cuentas públicas de muchos de los países
miembros o incluso definir exactamente
qué modelo de europa queremos
[Música]
el próximo 26 de mayo se celebrarán en
españa las elecciones al parlamento
europeo de una forma u otra este es el
momento en el que todos los ciudadanos
europeos tenemos la oportunidad de alzar
nuestra voz y decidir entre todos cuál
es el futuro que queremos para europa o
por qué tipo de unión apostamos así que
ya sabéis de momento si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante echarnos una mano
dándole al botón de like una vez más
muchas gracias al banco central europeo
por toda su ayuda y confianza para poder
realizar este vídeo y como siempre un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
tú y yo vamos a adentrarnos en este
mundo para ver
[Música]